my first time snowboarding looked a lot
like this it was pretty painful until
this little turtle showed up as an
Incredible Gift to put on my butt for my
next snowboarding experience in theory
this is perfect if you fall it's not
gonna hurt getting on the lift was
pretty interesting it didn't actually
fit under my butt so I had to kind of
sit at the side and scooch around not
getting off the lift that's a whole
nother story getting off the lift is
never easy and well as you can see here
it all happened so quickly I'm so sorry
but after that little tragedy we are off
to the races look how freaking cute he
is this being my second time
snowboarding I finally figured some
things out I finally was actually able
to make it down a bunch of runs without
falling I desperately knew this the
first time I went although I did take a
pretty hard tumble here and this is
where I was contemplating life uh my
butt didn't hurt but man I think I
twisted my knee so I think I need to get
some turtle knee pads